feel like I got hit with pepper spray it
is so hot
today what's going on everybody first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
ha1 it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by Kevin Love is a championship ring for
NBA all-star games under his belt but
can t handle Blair's Megadeth sauce with
liquid rage we'll find out today Kevin
welcome to the show
we share with edge government how are
you with hot food and yes we'll find out
but yeah hot wings I don't know if I'm
ready for this I don't know if I'm ready
for this either let the record show the
earliest shoot time that we've ever had
in the history of hot 1:10 a.m. hot
wings for breakfast cut are you ready to
get it going
then
[Applause]
[Music]
on this side here yep start on that side
go away yeah so I want to start by
taking it all the way back to the youth
baseball field in Lake Oswego where
right that's rare look at that that's a
hot ones different I don't know because
you not only nearly led the Lakers to a
Little League World Series but you also
shared a roster with an 11 years old
klay Thompson what do you remember about
klay Thompson the teammate on the Little
League field we can never get a word out
of them no he was it was very good we
were one game away from winning the
state championship was then what led to
regionals and then the blue league world
series but he was oh I can't say I saw
that coming up being one of the best you
know two guards all-time two-way player
I can shoot the ball exceptionally and
you know also I just championship rank
so two kids from like us we go there's
another youth sports memory that I want
to ask you about it's when you shattered
a backboard right high school game do
they have to end the game do they have a
spare to people not to install it what
with the aftermath so we actually final
score was actually four for nothing I
had I think a layup before that and then
had a breakaway dunk broke the backboard
and we actually had to play the middle
school the next night so they cancelled
that that game was done everybody went
home made to replace the backboard
nobody was happy about it and they
actually tried to bill bill my family
they went through the school of school
said we're not paying for this so they
went to Lake Oswego High School and said
well we're not paying for this and then
they actually asked my family to chip in
so today's meal notwithstanding I know
that you take your diet very seriously
and in fact your teammate Richard
Jefferson once said that you eat like an
eight-year-old lady who's trying to make
sure she's regular is that the most
savage thing a teammate has ever said
about your diet because I've heard you
said that you get teased about it often
I do probably him and Channing Frye gave
me give me the most [ __ ] about my diet
Richard's thirty six years old right 85
36 years old and still you know Duncan
three four five times a game he's just a
genetic freak so when they come on me
about my diet I don't
and then what's changed because in
college you described yourself as doughy
obviously which ones more understatement
I mean I would say I didn't work with a
nutritionist I didn't know how to eat
but more than anything I mean I came
from from High School where I was you
know I cleaned the plate asked for
seconds I was eating home-cooked meals
my mom was making me whatever I want I
didn't I knew nothing but garbage
disposals put it away how do you think
your ESPN the body spread would have
been different if you maybe did it
during your book it would it would have
never happened it would never happen I
don't think it's hit yet not need to
just chill these are free throws Kevin
just enjoy it go to front half so in my
book you're not a bonafide
NBA star until you start getting TV
cameos and you check that box in a
pretty big way early on when you did the
entourage episode with Eminem so many
brilliant stars are that manic energy
and that presence around them that make
them who they are and you know he was no
different that was interesting day at
Doug Allen house out to this huge decide
he said you know why don't you jump in
and when I was going to be here today so
he's like a big guy break up a fight and
that was a hit now I can feel a go 3 it
and then we know from the countless
snaps and instagrams of your Cavaliers
teammates that that locker rooms really
got its finger on the pulse of what's
new and what's up and coming in hip-hop
I mean we have a pretty eclectic group
we uh right now at you know Rick Ross's
new album you know Drake just put out
his new album guys are obviously debate
and trying about that you know Shelby's
putting out his new album you have some
playoff verses I was going to put out
for us to warm up to and we have a lot
of guys that yeah John fight about that
but it's fun what's the key to a really
good all Bros dance party and all Bros
dance party I mean don't don't take
yourself too seriously that's another I
wish I could explain it on here but
Richard Jefferson there's a certain song
out there throwback to like early 2000s
he knows won't talk about he'll see
Safa better know chillin
so far so good alright the next are the
showbiz little thing me I've called
explain that Graham what we do is we do
a deep dive and I guess Instagram 'full
interesting pictures that we think need
more context so I'll show you the
picture and then you just tell me the
bigger stories that sound good sounds
good right laptop please we spare no
expense here at how it ones Kevin Love
we just show the show the pics right off
the laptop alright the first one's
interesting it's a little before they
were famous with Kevin Love and Kevin
Durant it was the NBA top 100 camp
remember the first time I actually saw
him play he was playing for the DC Blue
Devils I couldn't believe how skinny was
how tall he was probably still you know
six nine six 10 at a time so had the
high foot you know he come down the
floor he would shake you cross you over
come between the legs shoot the three
next play come down same staying shaky
cross you're over go down the lane dunk
it and I mean he was one of those guys
that just moves a little you just see
move differently especially at that size
I've never seen anybody handle the ball
like that I mean the way he carried his
see the way he carried himself I said on
that I think this would be in the Hall
of Fame one day this is one of those
famous Cavalier fit picks something a
little suspicious though about the guy
on the far left my photoshopping
expertise isn't too great I know this
was a remember this was in Minnesota our
first year and it became such a thing
that Kevin's not in the photos and you
know bran and Tristan and swish and and
and shown pink eyes and I put him in the
photo so now I took it upon myself to
throw myself in have one more for you
Cleveland had a 52-year championship
drought and my guess is that there was a
lot of pent-up emotion what are the
weird things that you saw what are the
things that you remember what are the
stories he told the next day well I
remember that it was supposed to be a 45
minute run through I think it took three
and a half hours because you could tell
after 52 years that you know like we
want more we want more and there
originally were barricades to keep the
people away those went down and we just
had
security kind of walking by the cars and
kind of pushing everybody off but it was
while I mean every time you stood up you
know people going crazy the night before
we had actually gone out celebrating the
championship after having come back from
San Francisco and Oakland so we were a
little bit uh I guess under the weather
[Music]
I'm trying to eat most of the wings so
I'm not like so that the commenters
don't get to ride I don't want to see
that yeah I heard you say that you get
through road trips by binge watching
movies but I was a little bit surprised
to learn that you have a special
fondness for spaghetti westerns and in
particular director Sergio Leone oh I
don't mean to stereotype professional
athletes but that's a very strange
little interesting Kevin Love back Toit
I think it was early on just kind of
being obsessed with with Clint Eastwood
or even that that time period without
exposing too much my alias everywhere I
go is from good to bad me ugly that's
how much I when you check into the hotel
yeah and then I know that you're a huge
Game of Thrones head what other NBA
players do you find yourself kind of
talking to about the show well I say as
far as our team goes it's a jump jump
the big game itself - huge Game of
Thrones guy and his take on not just the
show but everything is so not what I
expected it so Leslie oh yeah like he's
like it I think it's going to go here
and he goes off on this you know 5 to 10
minute explanation of where you know
Ahri's Arya is going to be now in the
show or this is what's going to happen
to sosser Jon Snow and I'm just like
yeah ok Shelton that's great
[Music]
so I'd be remiss if I didn't ask about
last year's NBA Finals because it's not
every day that hot ones has a guest who
came back from a 3-1 series deficit and
then in the final minute you were Dean
up Steph Curry in that game 7 matchup
what is your headspace like when that's
happening because you could just pull up
from you know 6 feet beyond right point
line he could try to go to the rim
you're just kind of like on your feet
what was the debate in the old school
when it gets up though you got a black
down yeah blacked out yeah it was one of
those moments where he could have pulled
up from really anywhere as long as I
contested the shot stayed in front of
them and you know forced him into
something really tough from you know
twenty three twenty four feet and I'd be
okay and I remember he gave the ball up
to draymond after I had you know move my
feet gave the ball up passed it back
actually let him get it back of course
you know two-time MVP unanimous MVP that
year so I let him get it back and try to
force him into a tough shot throws it up
I think he was short on that Bron got
the rebound
that was it and then after that there's
this great picture of you Huggy LeBron
that has been memed by the internet a
million times over once I saw that the
shot was long I mean I looked for
whoever I didn't want to be one of those
guys running around looking for somebody
to hug or you know fist pump or or
anything like that so no I went right
for Bron just you know that was it
everybody was a I think probably most
most proud of the most happy for for
Bron and I was an exception all right
Kevin so this is zombie apocalypse we're
getting to where things get kind of
serious over here okay
[Music]
all right ones up up in the nose right
off the bat off it I told you I'm socks
what so as we've talked about already
you did pose nude for sports
illustrating of a ton of spreads which
by resume has to make you like a legit
top male model what's your secret for
how best to make love to the camera I'll
be apocalypse I get to wear what I want
I get to work with a lot of great people
and I'm really trying to think of an
answer while this thing's burning or not
and I can't what's the key to stay and
loose during a shoot because you know
people don't understand about shoots
shoots can be exhausting you know nobody
ever wants to cry for what I've done
them I've done a bunch of them like I'm
up on my feet for an hour I feel like
I've worked a full day you know if you
want to loosen up it's okay to have an
adult beverage
what backdrop would you pick for a
lookbook if Kevin Love were art
directing the spread what would be your
backdrop what it'd be Park City Utah
would it be someplace else
nice drop to Park City um yeah maybe
maybe somewhere in southern Utah be
really nice something in the the Wild
West so this is the bomb - bomb
I don't want to talk to you about your
time at UCLA for a second because I feel
like nobody ever you see it in you a
telegram I'm no superhero right I'm no
superhero no one ever thinks about that
people think I'm like so tough so hard
with these hotdogs I'm not proud right
now I'm no longer ole is not a good
choice well there's the water I realize
that our act like taboo oh no no no no
no no no don't try to Travis Kelce
speaking of athletes he came in here
with like that kind of vibe like you can
drink water you can drink milk I've
noticed the athletes that do get kind of
like competitive with it which I
actually like watching from like this
side of the table is very interesting to
me but no have some water have some milk
all right go to chill that's all right
what was Russell Westbrook's most
annoying habit as a college roommate we
had thermostat battles
oh so while we're going through battling
right here yeah he would he was doing
you know 74 75 degrees wake up in the
middle and I turned that thermostat up
and for me I'm you know 68 but that
little little bit of heat really makes a
difference 74 75 because that's like
significant it's significant for me I
was very responsive to that sweating
wake up in Illinois that couldn't get me
sleep and you know of course he comes
out and is Russell Westbrook but it was
not and I'm really trying to keep it
together right now you know like I say
he before we started rolling I've the
Mad Dog three five seven was the one I
was not looking forward why can you tell
me what's from the response from
everyone else that's been on the show I
thought was a mine this should make you
be delirious but I said that is not hot
like in this woman's honor oh it's time
to lay to clock did they do their
children or to them it's always that
second to last one right
ready go there Stewart that strange
being on the show having like watched it
you know you know I really like this set
[Music]
that ones stuck on the punching bag
mm-hmm
no it's fun when you're a fan of the
show and actually get to get to come on
yeah and I guess you always feel like
it's a good idea to be on shows you
watch and you look at one again I'm
really sorry but again I'll take it
personal I don't think a personal I
don't think anyone's ever walked out of
here being like oh yeah that was a good
use of my time so one of the most
interesting Kevin Love factoids and I
know it gets brought up to you all the
time is that your Uncle Mike with a lead
singer for the Beach Boys I know that
you weren't exactly hit with the music
plug in the exact same way but you did
have that feature on that Damian Lillard
song dropping dimes if you could
collaborate with any artist in the world
who's your dream collaboration right now
my dream collaboration probably chance I
met him over the summer is that the
ESPYs and his performance at the ESPYs
is unbelievable what's your favorite
Beach Boys deep cut beach boys deep cut
define deep cut I don't want to hear
like Good Vibrations feel like I got hit
with pepper spray you do that's a second
it is so hot another chip
I feel like you might be able to cut out
like the last five minutes of this
because I'm not getting any answers out
of ya no no that's the good stuff
that's the good stuff the question is
whatever nobody that's my brain has
stopped working in by what was this one
again goes by her after you got caught
Kevin yeah Wow
all right so Kevin as you know it's
tradition around here to put a little
dab on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to and careful it's a
little bit of a runny tap okay
[Music]
that's good okay uncle great I'll go
crazy all right you know Kevin cheers
Cheers
[Music]
just feel alive
do you now more than ever
Wow so this is the final wing and it's
like Game seven and the clocks running
out and I need you to put your dancing
shoes on for this one because I do have
a quick MBA rapid-fire before we get you
out the door
so I'll just hit you with a bunch of
questions you just give me the first
thing that comes to mind okay let's go
most difficult player to defend not Dirk
Nowitzki Calvin Duran who's the most
savage trash talker in the game right
now I grew up with it being Paul Pierce
so Paul was always a guy that could back
it up and also barged a lot especially
when he was on Boston yeah I mean it he
he's the truth I mean it has that
nickname for a reason most underrated
player you've ever shared a floor with a
friend his player oh shoot
well it's Ted to say my answer that
would be Russell Westbrook I mean when I
came to college I mean oh he was you
know went to the UCLA medicine I
remember he was just going there and
kill everybody leave like nothing
happened hit the weight room and I said
madness keeps going to be special
finally good win in a cage match between
you and draymond Green
cage match cage may have lost plenty of
plenty Austin 3:16 Roanoke stone cold
steve austin saucy all i got weren't in
a cage match Kevin Love got the edge and
you know what else you might win is in a
wing eating competition because he
cleared the board as well Kevin Love you
made it through you know how it goes
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life appreciate it you know
we're trying to win another NBA
championship you know it's all going to
come down to to us you know being
healthy and locking in so you're good to
be here today we're in my banana
republic like I said wool wasn't a great
choice but I have my traveler genes on
there nice and you know feel great
especially when I'm sweating after mad
dog hair feel good
and that's hot one
my face is really hot hey what's going
on hot ones fans if you liked the video
maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you liked
the video subscribe thank you very much
I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend